dans la région c'est le début des
vendanges une cinquantaine de communes
d'ile-de-france à renouer avec cette
tradition hier à joinville la confrérie
des maîtres goustiers a donné le coup
d'envoi
et tout le monde s'est retrouvé autour
d'un verre pour célébrer avec faste et
gaieté cette fête de la vigne et du vin
et jean philippe lemaire et jérôme
dutrieux étaient de la partie au pied
des immeubles 475 qui est de ving ils
ont été plantés sur ce coteau de
joinville-le-pont le 1er avril 1989 à
l'initiative des vignerons de la
confrérie des maîtres boost y ait de
joinville des épicuriens qui oeuvre pour
les produits du terroir et le maintien
des traditions il tout simplement
l'histoire de notre val de bar de joie
il en particulier tous les coteaux qui
borde la mer était planté deux rings
depuis le haut moyen âge des vignes qui
servait justement à abreuver nos
parisiens
alors comment ça se passe les vendanges
c'est pas trop dur
non c'est très agréable très très
désagréable et cnit et un soleil
magnifique donc nous sommes vraiment
ravis
près de 600 kg de raisins ont été
récoltés des fruits qui ont un peu
souffert de la maladie alors les petites
mains sont à pied d'oeuvre pour enlever
les grains abîmée attention grand
peintre yan elles viennent nous aurons
des relais
les grains sont séparés des grappes par
cette machine
ensuite les vignerons pressait près
c'est vrai c'est pour l'instant en forme
je vais m'arrêter
c'est bon pour la sieste le vin du pays
s'appelle le gang un assemblage de
cépages sauvignon et sémillon un vin que
l'on boit entre amis de la confrérie
le cru 1997 se présente bien aussi bien
que le cru 1996 p tit dans les verts ale
jet